my guest tonight is an award-winning
filmmaker she is best known for looking
at nostalgic schlock from the 80s and
90s as nostalgia chick but also looks at
some good stuff once in a while and on
top of that she is also in the process
of trying to write either the best or
the worst novel depending on your point
of view with her webseries 50 shades of
green please welcome Lindsey Ellis how
are you doing Lindsey I'm pretty good
herido I am very good I cannot complain
so um honestly as you very well know you
were brought on to channel Lawson to
bring in a more feminine outlook on de
Stael chick media so I guess my first
question is why are you such a bad me
because I mean used at the glasses
they're gone the beard is now coming
Austin there's a different you lost it
because that took away like 50% me I am
that guy of the glass no no it was a
different ethic so it was like the sexy
librarian you're not the sexy librarian
I I got some nice jokes here I can you
don't get that push-up bra okay it's no
brand but Brad's got some nice ones but
you also don't pull your hair back have
like the single strand I'm working if I
had hair to grow I would do that well I
own it
I don't know I definitely kind of toned
back a lot of stuff as time went by ice
like my makeup but Gus super super plain
I stopped wearing the bow tie the
glasses usually were because at any
given time I didn't know where they were
except for like at first because I pop
it like they were reading less I'd pop
the lens out because the glare from the
lights you were trying to fake in there
oh right
no I do I do wear glasses but like those
glasses I had to pop the pop the lenses
out because the lights reflected in them
and then I lost those
I just lose the hell out of everything
and like I went through like three
bowties before I said fuck it no more
bowtie I don't lose my hair so I kept
the pigtails
but the reason I'm such a bad you is
because I'm not you um I was not raised
as a boy and we weren't really raised
watching the same things and we don't
have the same perspective on them
therefore I make a pretty piss-poor you
uh but surprisingly even five years on
it I still get shit about that
so thanks Doug your beard will grow in I
yeah yeah good that the hair loss me
you'll do a part tonight Mary he'll be
fantastic oh I think I've had a few
Bart's nightmares I just sort of swept
them under the rug done rather then
example under the internet yeah I just
sort of like rather than acknowledge my
failures I'm just sort of like okay next
time we'll do them what dude oh we could
talk about that if you want
i I got more interesting questions in my
panic cuz dune is a boring ass movie no
is a boring ass movie but I do have I I
do have legitimate reasons for why I
felt bad and I never told you this but
um honestly the day that I felt really
bad about the doing review was when I
watched your Independence Day review and
so curious what the connection is well
you you got a lot of things wrong that
were explained in the movie because you
were like why didn't they do this and I
was like that was in the movie it was
just sort of like in a little throwaway
line and and I kind of realized that
like all my frustration with dune was it
wasn't clear but it was there like the
stuff that wasn't obvious it wasn't
there it was just not it was told in its
little David Lynch II way even if you
had read the book like cuz you know in
the like you I I didn't know what the
vagina monsters were cuz in the book
there were just dudes that were ugly and
fat and but they were human and in the
vagina monster is supposed to be human
and I didn't realize that that that
thing in the tube was the same thing as
the as the
spacefill things has been forever since
ever in this book I still hate it by the
way why is so glad that my botch up has
cleared the way for your botched no I
really really kind of humbled me I'm so
glad my big-ass mistake humbled you okay
I think that well I think that's
important because I mean when I watch
stuff like is only like red letter media
I'm a big fan of them but they get stuff
like sometimes they'll say super sexist
stuff or sometimes they'll just get
something completely wrong or they'll
Jewish and like I am a still big fan of
theirs but they get shit wrong and um it
doesn't like cuz I remember there were
times in my life but I'd see something
make me so mad when someone got
something wrong and I understand that
impulse so I heard that I was like ah it
wasn't so much that I like was super
wrong as I just wasn't paying close
enough attention and then I did more and
I still really dislike d'un but for
basically the same reasons but I now you
get the reasons right I would just say
like I you think I disrespected it for
stupid reasons that were based in my not
paying attention now you got into a film
reviewing very much of the attraction of
wanting to make films Oh what is the
attraction of both was the attraction of
seeing films and making films are they
entirely different or do you feel
they're actually pretty similar um I've
met a lot of people that kind of go both
ways on that uh I started in academia um
I I never like I guess I kind of did
like the doofy little high school movies
thing but um I when I was in college I
only did academic stuff like I only did
film history and film criticism in film
theory and um uh it was weird because we
did overlap some with the film
production kids and I
hated it like they hated the film theory
stuff they just did not understand like
why do we need to have a context for the
things we like why do we need to look at
film as art why do we need to understand
their sociological context and I guess
it was like I I knew that first before I
knew production cuz I mean like I was
always interested in it like I'd you
know like watch the DVDs the behind the
scenes stuff like especially the Lord of
the Rings DVDs with like all the stuff
about sound design they show what like
they get from lunch they show everything
on those DVDs and I thought that was
awesome and I guess like by the end of
college I was like maybe someday and you
know then after getting fired I was like
now now is the time because you know it
was 2008 if that tells you anything mmm
2008 job market was not good uh so uh it
was basically like sort of my core
understanding of film and I was also
writing a lot at the time like I feel
like writing even pros like Roberts
exact what you say rioting idea when
you're writing a lot just break-in the
windows you know I mean like no one had
any jobs so we just go lewd on the
weekends it's fun very overrated
yeah but I mean basically late to me was
like understanding story structure was
like it's one thing to understand in
like a theoretical land but
understanding it you really kind of have
to do it and I didn't really understand
that until like I was doing it a lot
like at the end of college and then
after that and then then I went to film
school basically out of like you know
not really knowing what else to do with
my life and and then and I wouldn't say
like my hesitation had anything to do
with lack of passion headed everything
to do with money
um but that's another story so um I
guess it's sort of like a Venn diagram
sort of think is to me they're very
interconnected to a lot of people
they're not obviously you go you review
a lot of things and not necessarily all
negative you talked about positive
things as well in your opinion what is
the job of a critic
I don't know do you think we're critics
uh I didn't ask if you were critic I
said what's the job of a critic you're
putting words in my mouth mmm okay only
think what is the job of a critic
um I again I feel like there's this sort
of overlap there's like the Entertainer
there's the entertainment critic like
Roger Ebert sort of pioneered that with
you know at the movies
and then there's the academic who puts
the films in their context um and I feel
like there's this sort of like this Venn
diagram of these three things and
ideally a critic should be right in the
middle you know you should be the critic
you give your opinion should be the
academic you have an education to back
that up and you should be an entertainer
you do this in an entertaining way and
um I think I mean personally and
obviously I get a little pushback on
this I feel like context is important
your sociological context your media
context your um even technological
especially and budget oh god don't get
me started girl but boy they I think
that ideally that that would be the
answer but it's it's not always easy to
hit all three and I certainly feel in
some in some states in some cases well
what is the toughest part when you're
putting together any sort of production
well whether it be a review or film a
short film whatever it really has to do
with the production honestly like in my
experience the people you work with is a
biggie how much money you have is a
biggie how much time you have is a
biggie I would say the people is the
biggest and how well you die with them
and is there drama drama really hurts a
production especially like I mean in it
this is like this isn't limited to
student films like every every
production has the potential for drama
Christian Bale has taught us that um a
few Russell Crowe's but money is also a
biggie and trying to keep things under
your butt
like I wanted to look this way but I I
guess also just it really kind of
depends on how much of a perfectionist
you are like because like my documentary
I even today to this day I can't even
watch it and it's not because of subject
matter it's because I just it's just so
flawed in my in my view and I'm just
like well several awards disagree with
you early two or three only two or three
you know with all the other two or three
award-winning documentary joins oh there
there were many more but it's like yeah
you know it really kind of depends it
really depends on the production and
also the director and what they want and
like in my case they were producer
issues um but our or I've also worked
with producers that were just great and
they were what do you want I will help
you I will just work so hard for it so I
really I'd say the people the answer is
people all right that a cross off all
that are people yes but a hour later
people keep mm-hmm it's all comes back
up it really is let me film is
collaborative and like if you drive with
people it's gonna be much easier might
not be better like some of the best
movies ever have come from like
incredibly strained productions like you
know all half a Kubrick's movies are the
first Star Wars but um you know at the
same time do you want to be I have a
good product you would be miserable you
know they're actually something I've
noticed a lot of times at least from
interviews from what I've noticed is
that a lot of people lot of directors
that I consider not making very good
movies are usually very nice and very
kind and every time I see him on
commentaries whatever I say these sound
like smart kind people and you almost
got a wonder if there is sort of a I
guess it's gonna vary from production
production but if there is serve a
connection to sort of the nicer the
person maybe serve the less likely it is
that film is gonna be more artistically
pleasing possibly yes I know so sort of
a weird comparison no no I think it's
fair I think there are directors that
know how to play the game and then they
get very far by that
they may not necessarily make very good
movies and the directors that know what
they want and what they want might be
terrible but what they want might also
end up being the best product and and
then there are the ones that listen to
their friends and that can also be
terrible but I mean look at like
understand anandwali
like that movie would have been
completely different if Andrew Stanton
had had complete creative control
because he listened to a lot of people
in the process of making it and that
influenced a story and when you want to
look at an understanding with no input
from anyone else we have one it's called
John Carter and we saw how that went uh
now compared to other online reviewers
when you review something you don't
usually go in order whether it be a game
or movie you don't go in order of how
it's delivered you go very much like
let's talk about character let's talk
about story let's talk about elements
and talk about that as a group serve
more like a traditionally written review
uh why does that style attract you more
than uh going in order usually well
largely um it's in less violation of
copyright law um it you shouldn't going
telling the complete synopsis in the
plot
unless it's serving a point that you're
trying to make uh that's not fair use
although I often fail in fair use uh
sorry fair use good it's really hard I
mean like I know fairies pretty well but
I just it's hard to keep all that shit
together um but but also just because uh
that tends to be the stuff that I like
to watch you know like stuff that's more
themed driven than just point by point
because you know like point by point
more Mystery Science Theater II um I
mean you know obviously there's a place
for that but um I I guess I find it more
fulfilling when it's more focused and I
guess that's also kind of why it takes
me longer to write things because it's
like well if I'm going to talk about I
know Mean Girls what's the theme soon
like talking about Addams Family it's
like well what's a theme well obviously
it's in this context of shitty family
movies from the early 90s which we had a
lot more of back then
because the demographics are different
and so I guess I like to put things in a
context and that lends itself better to
sa form rather than just put making it
about the movie and very important the
puffles
and then this happened that that's what
pulls it together the Pope oh yeah I
just kinda also kind of perhaps
erroneously assumed that people have
seen the thing I'm talking about um what
is the attraction to nostalgia for you
specifically um nostalgia was originally
considered a disease uh we are sick
people yeah I mean we are anyway but
bring in this - that just makes it even
worse well I find that very interesting
that it was originally considered a sort
of disease of the mind that I just sort
of overtook you in times of stress and I
think that is in a way very true but
what they think now is it's actually
kind of good for you like it creates
endorphins um and because I mean like I
find that I do that - like sometimes
I'll get like really nostalgic like a
few weeks ago I was usually depressed
and we started talking about phantom and
so we get like really into phantom and
we watch like the phantom live at Albert
would make these jokes and like because
like phantom is super nostalgic for me
but at the same time I feel like when
you're nostalgic for something you're
completely irrational about it you know
and I see that and I find them so
strange all the time when people um uh
like no Ninja Turtles with the greatest
thing ya know I love it but I know it's
crazy yeah like no transformers was like
time to know okay guys um and people get
like they kind of attach to their
identity to it and like this sort of
like exists in this haze of magical
childhood which is just not reality and
so I find that sort of dichotomy of like
haze of magical childhood versus what it
fucking was like in the case of
transformers it was literally a
commercial because regulation laws
changed when Reagan got elected and so
basically children's programming changed
dramatically in the early 80s
which is why we had so many TV shows
that were based on toys which we didn't
have in the 70s and so I find that very
fascinating when you sort of look at
like wow it was awesome when I was like
2 and now it's like oh there's a big
adult world context for it so I find
that sort of like clash but a lot of
people hate that you're like no but my
beautiful childhood like yes die
beautiful child ah what since he brought
up yet you reminded me of this now I
have to ask because I know the answer
but I want ya else to know uh how did
you Lisa
Anela meat oh yeah um see I I clawed
tooth and nail to get my dad buy me a
computer cuz we were like one of the
last families in the country to get one
cuz he was such a neo Luddite and um
when he did this was also the summer
that I got super into phantom speaking
of which
number how did you try to explain it
it's not gonna sound cool yes oh hi I'm
Josh I'm be incredibly dirty ok ok uh so
um the very first thing I did when I got
into phantom was I was like I discovered
phantom fanfiction and I swear to God I
read it because basically this is berrin
was like the year 2000 I like it was a
much smaller internet back then so I
were like every single phantom fanfic on
the internet and I thought it was just
the greatest thing what's it called Fant
thick
fanfic with a pH OSU Fanta Fick would
have been because then we can say but I
digress yeah yeah it's a it's hard when
you're discussing it but then again most
these people never meet in real life
anyway there you go but um so I actually
I wrote an essay about this on che
apocalypse about the this the fanfic
that I rode this glorious like this is
before I even understood the term
MarySue like it was the most gratuitous
self-insert and like I don't think I had
magical powers but my name is Athena and
I had black eyes like the guitars from
lip biscuit and Harley's Pacific yeah no
I was super deluxe Coutu is weird and
phantom a thing come on you haven't
quite
we and so I meant like these these four
other girls named Lisa nella Angie and
Kristen Kersten we're going to talk to
anymore but the other three we still
talk we met on the firm's at
fanfiction.net
and I'm gonna be the bridesmaids and Mel
and I are gonna be the bridesmaids and
lisas wedding and then she's gonna be
there too so like we all still like we
met between the ages of 13 and 16 you
know depending on who we were but yeah
so and but it's weird it's like yeah we
met on fanfiction.net and we've been
friends ever since
so Phantom of the Opera and fan fiction
bring people together
it's chant was the secret of life that's
what everyone's been missing phantom and
fanfiction they show gone together
closer you gotta hit at the right time
they're just the right time yeah and
move to the right city cuz nella and I
were like she was like I want to go to
NYU and I like ah me too
let's go to NYU we'll be roommates two
years later we did this there you go I
was expecting a bot in there if I don't
know and we did it yeah that was like I
mean this is one of those things that
you think would never ever happen cuz
you're a dumb kid but that was exactly
what happened like we both got it didn't
why you until that was that um how many
awards did the a-word win not that many
um I'll see like two and two and a half
two and a half cut it in half out that
works I was like a finalist in an
honoree mention in a couple and went to
for another thing
so I guess three cumulatively is if you
you combined them uh the documentary
room for those who don't know is about
abortion were you very bravely in my
opinion make yourself the subject and
did you see your review about it unmute
oh oh the one with a tape are talking
about Twilight Breaking Dawn and splice
it when to make it about your movie I
had so many people that were so
heartbroken they were like I can't
believe dog would say these that I you
know I have to be honest I found it
pretty fun I drew the rabbit out like
that just total bad taste but this is
fuck me
what an idiot you were like his foil
again I guess she's kind of but but
people were really hurt by it they were
like like daddy was the nice I can't
believe you'd say such mean things well
that made that spread it to a good
edited troll I guess yeah I guess I was
a good edit role oh but you make
yourself the subject of it and what what
I'm always amazed at whenever I see it
is that whatever side of the argument
you want your on uh everybody sees the
humanity of it and you can't help but
just be struck in the face with it what
possessed you to do not only a risky
subject but in such a risky way well
honestly because I hadn't I
I hadn't seen that like um I after it
happened I I was taking this I I decided
to take this documentary one which was
advanced project one at USC this would
have been my third semester and I was
doing sound for a documentary and as I
was doing it I was taking the pitch
class that you had to take you know if
you do want to direct one um and as I
was doing it I was watching these other
documentaries about abortion like like a
fire as a biggie and there are some some
some other less famous ones speak out I
was another um no that was kind of a
Talking Heads more than a documentary
but yeah there are quite a few but but
they're all about the debate and I
really hated like a fire I loved it
which is that that's uh I mean okay I
take that back
I admired how much effort went into it
because it was filmed over the course of
many many years is made by the guy who
did the American History X and the the
intent was to get all of the different
perspectives and also it followed like
some people who like were affected by
abortion clinic bombings and
the thing I hated about it was it like
at the end of the day I was just like
who cares who queue who gives a shit
about these people that just have all
these opinions most of them were men the
only person that the only real
interesting subject he had and it was
Norma McCorvey who was the original Jane
Roe and she very publicly regrets having
been a part of roe v-- wade and so I
thought that was very interesting but
for them for the most of it it was just
like so hey I'm an atheist pro-lifer or
like hey I'm a crazy bomber person and
I'm just like this has nothing to do
with the reality of what it's like to go
through it and I guess like that was
what made me realize like how much the
experience of the woman going through it
and took some extent than then it's just
completely taken out of the picture
like I'm the feminist side it's all
about like you know you're not allowed
to hurt you're not allowed to to have
any sort of complex feelings on the
subject on the pro-life side it's all
about the baby all about the baby if you
are hurting it's just because you're
you're wrong and you'll get over that
and so like I and I just I felt like I'd
never seen anything that kind of
captured the the reality of it like the
actual experience of it at least in
documentary form so that that was my
intent was just to sort of find other
people and originally I wanted to
include more men but I think due to the
time limit it could be more than 26
limit 26 minutes um we couldn't do that
or it did but it kind of messed up the
flow which frustrated my producer but
but so it ended up mostly being about
like the experiences of the women and
because just that is so often not really
considered relevant to the discussion
and this of course is building up to
your magnum opus I mean that was good
but the magnet that is 50 shades of
green what can you tell us about
creating this book that it tell us
exactly what the project is and what the
goal of it is
well it was just we wanted to do an
interactive web series was the thing and
we're all writers like a mountain illa
and I write and Lisa does too although
she wasn't initially involved oh because
she was writing her book yeah a
different book and so we were like well
we and I we'd been trying to figure out
how to incorporate books more into the
video and say we're like well this could
be a good way of doing it would be on
making it interactive and basically
letting the viewer decide what it was
that we do so we're like alright we're
going to make a book and then you decide
like the only thing is like it has to be
like a knockoff of these super popular
romance novels like 50 shoes like I was
like it's going to be either Fifty
Shades of Grey knockoff or Twilight and
we were laid in one of your Fifty Shades
of Grey knockoff because we really
didn't want to write like 90 sex scenes
in like 400 pages I got go but you got a
few in there yeah well I didn't like it
work well what people ended up voting
for was like it should be young adult
like um in the vein of Twilight or
Hunger Games and so we were like yeah
cuz originally we were like alright it's
gonna be like Twilight with aliens and
then the fans were like no it should be
Twilight
Zulu and so we were like there we go and
so so it ended up being like a lot of
fun like the actual writing process and
reading the comments and the suggestions
that people had they were because we
originally that's started like I like a
year ago on Twitter one night I was just
joking about Twilight with aliens and
then like people were giving me all
these suggestions about like I want to
kill you with my cloths if mister alien
I knew that it was love like that and it
was just so funny and and so that that
was sort of like we we were just like
hey people are more creative than we are
listen let's let's involve them what do
you feel Cthulhu is so popular right now
this is a character has been around this
creation has been around for years but
he's huge now he's everywhere he's the
punchline of any joke I honestly don't
know he's only in one Lovecraft story
really it's pretty short
everybody remembers him everybody
remembers good I think it must have to
do with the role-playing games uh which
are real big I I don't I uh I really
don't I think it's also because like of
all of the other Lovecraftian horrors
he's also the one that like kind of has
the most distinct look like visually and
so you can be like when salut ex bad
shit goes down and like okay um but III
guess it's sort of like the the the
character equivalent of rocks fall
everyone dies you know it's just like
sort of like game over clues here and
what is the title of the magnum opus its
awoken awoke it it wasn't written like
it was either gonna be the call or
awoken the call turned into a bad Halle
Berry movies yeah it'll probably
forgotten very quickly but forgot us I
think a mocha it's a better time yeah we
were was awoken and then we were like
what was the second one it was gonna be
like forsaken and then these have to be
real titles though okay well we it was
weird because like the the the promise
we picked was a little dated because um
publishing the you know the world of
publishing it scrawls along at a snail's
pace but by the time something like you
know the Hunger Games comes out that
ship has already sailed you know like by
the time the Hunger Games hit it big in
2009-2010 dystopia it was kind of over
like if you're submitting a dystopian
book it's like we got too many of these
and so by the time like you know like
Twilight came out two years later there
was this huge glut of paranormal because
it's about how long it takes to but kid
a book published um
and so like uh with the with this
particular genre it's it's it's really
quite dated because paranormal romance
is done now like now it's all about
that's so last ten years ago yeah that
was so Bush administration but yeah it's
a is what we thought it was still funny
you know but because it's like a it's
dated our fake author doesn't realize it
stated trying to cash it yes so like
people like paranormal romance right um
I like to end every interview with two
questions they're polar opposites the
first one is what is the hardest thing
whether it be professionally or
personally you've ever had to go through
and how did you get through it mm you
like to throw those softball questions
don't you I do they get great reactions
oh well thing I'll leave the personally
went off professionally you know what
honestly uh I have to say querying a
novel like it's weird because filmmaking
is so nerve-racking but it's also
collaborative and it's like because I
because I wrote an of another novel
which is not the Cthulhu novel which
I've been kind of picking out for last
year and I wearing it for a while and
that you're so alone
and not in a way with like film you've
got producers and you've got your you
know sitar for your buddies and if
you're all in it together but with with
novel writing you're just like on an
island like I hope somebody likes me and
it's so so hard and the worst part is
like no one's got a gun to your head
making you do it you have to do it
yourself or you will have just just
completely wasted your time and that I
mean I know that sounds like completely
lame but honestly it's like with all the
filmmaking stuff I've done the
collaborative effort ultimately makes it
easier because you've always got someone
that it's someone else that's vested in
it but whenever it's just because
another thing about fiction writing is
it is like I feel like I know Stephenie
Meyer better than I know my mother you
know oh I don't know how you should feel
about that well I mean I think that I
think that's true for everyone I think
that's kind of why people are so turned
off by Al James's it's so personal and I
think all fiction writing is just to a
certain extent like fiction writing is
way more personal than say memoir
writing you know you know more about Dan
Brown than you do David Sedaris
um so it's like on the one hand you're
so alone on the other hand you are late
completely bare and all your issues are
there in fiction form in a way that you
yourself probably don't get as opposed
to me more aware it's completely
deliberate or documentary for that
matter so I would have to say a querying
fiction for professional publication has
been the hardest thing I've had to do
and how did you get through it I haven't
I'm still doing I'll bet I would say
like I I'm still in the process but um
just numbing yourself to criticism I've
also you know been making friends in the
publishing industry um get I guess it
kind of makes it less terrifying and you
know just reading a lot and being like
I'm better than this right I could do
this and then you read you read your
stuff you're like I think I used too
many adverbs and finally what is the one
thing again either professionally or
personally that you are the most proud
of that you've ever done hmm well I'm
gonna say Freddy got fingered is up
there the review afraid yeah like I I am
I feel like that's my legacy like long
after my bones have turned to ash there
will be a gif of me getting hot dogs
thrown in the face on BuzzFeed like that
is my longest lasting legacy um yeah
well I mean and I guess I've done some
stuff I'm proud of I mean like I mean
this type of person it's like once I put
something out there I'm like it's the
worst and I never watch it again um
Freddy got fingered that's it yeah
that's me yeah it's the least worst of
the online stuff I've done I I was proud
of that and also like the one I did with
Jamie that Disney needs more gay people
responded well to that so I liked that
one
and also the like done some minor stuff
that that hasn't really seen the light
of day
that I like but I guess I'll wait to see
if it holds up to the scrutiny and
others before I can say I'm proud
very nice well this has been Lindsay
Ellis and this was shut up and talk now
this is where we talk to each other in
the music plays over okay I'd like to
say it oh oh yeah yeah that's a well
chat about it'll be awesome
oh cool we so much fun we're gonna like
be throwing punches and stuff like
that's gonna be awesome and cool yeah
cool